hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll if you were following the
presidential primary campaign here in
the United States here in 2020 one of
the most unusual candidates was Andrew
yang who had a set of very specific
interesting messages that we don't
usually hear in presidential campaigns
he was very concerned in particular
about the oncoming wave of automation
that is gonna change the nature of the
workforce and so his idea was that
robots or automated technologies more
generally would gradually replace
people's jobs and therefore we had to
provide a universal basic income to let
people live and and flourish in a world
that had much less work in it so aside
from what economic policy you think is
the best idea this question of whether
or not automation really will replace
people's jobs is a very important one so
that's what we're gonna discuss today
our guest is John Danaher who's a senior
lecturer in the law school at the
national university of ireland and his
interests are in the intersection of law
narrow science technology especially
artificial intelligence and so forth
John has his own podcast called
philosophical disquisitions that you can
find a link to in the blog post and he's
written a book called automation and
utopia human flourishing in a world
without work so to put it very
simplistically we'll get into more
details in the podcast of course but
basically John says yes automation is
coming yes it's gonna put us all out of
work and yes that is awesome because
once we don't need to work we can do all
these other wonderful things and so the
question is well what are these
wonderful things will we really do them
well we feel fulfilled without a job to
go to 9:00 to 5:00 is there some moral
hazard associated with not being a
working person with having all the
leisure time you want
so John tries to make the argument that
it's actually kind of the good thing
that you might expect naively you're
still allowed to work you could do
things but we'll have a much better
society and much better individual lives
when we can choose what work to do
what work not to do it's extremely
thought-provoking and very futuristic in
a down-to-earth way this is something
that might actually be approaching us so
it's important I think to think these
issues through to be prepared for what
might be a very very dramatic change in
how we organize human society I should
note that we had an audio issue for the
first 20 minutes of this podcast it's
not really bad it's just that the wrong
microphone was getting used so and then
we switch after 20 minutes is over so if
you persevere through the first 20
minutes the audio quality will get a lot
better just because despite both being
podcasters the technology sometimes
baffles us and with that let's go
John Danaher welcome to the mindscape
podcast Thank You Sean it's a pleasure
to be here I'm actually a big fan of
this podcast so it's a bit of a thrill
to be honest well before I forget we
should advocate your podcast right do
you have one I do yes so I run a blog
called philosophical disquisitions it's
a cumbersome title but I picked it years
ago and second with it
and I have a podcast of the same name
associated with that it's mainly about
philosophy of Technology and the ethics
of technology but I do some occasional
audio essays that's other topics cool we
will definitely link to it in the blog
post I put up for this episode but
speaking of technology and and
philosophy and so forth but you're not a
professional philosopher or is that your
training you're in a law school right
yeah I am so I'm not a philosopher by
training I book more by application I
suppose I my typical joke is that two
lawyers I'm the philosopher yeah and two
philosophers I'm a lawyer oh I know that
one well yes okay so you're we're gonna
get into this story that you advocate
about giving ourselves over to the
robots taking over and why that might be
a good thing but I wanted to start as
you start in the book because you have
some great numbers some great stories to
really drive home how fast things are
changing just just to quote one you say
that a hundred thousand sorry ten
thousand years ago the percentage of the
vertebrate biomass on earth that was
either human beings or our controlled
animals right our livestock and our pets
was 0.1% of the vertebrate biomass on
earth and by now it's closer to 98% so
we have one the human beings have taken
over is that safe to say yeah statistic
that I recount it's actually something
that Daniel Dennett uses a lot in talks
it is so that's right got it from and
since I published a book people have
pointed out to me they did I don't know
if that's a fully reliable statistic
whether it really is 98% it's an
estimates based on a number of
assumptions that could be questionable
but I think the general gist of it which
is that humans and human livestock
human agriculture now really dominate
the planet in an unprecedented way in
comparison to what was the case before
the Agricultural Revolution yeah I'm
willing to believe that it's not 98% but
we're arguing about whether it's 96% now
well there is 40% like it is most of
what's going on here on earth right now
I would think and then you go through
the various revolutions we've had with
agriculture and technology and so forth
and it really drives home not just human
dominance of the planet but how rapidly
it is all happening right right and
people have are probably familiar with
some of these graphs that you show of
you know the number of calories consumed
or burned per person per country since
the Industrial Revolution and you see
this hockey stick like graph where if
you zoom out it looks like nothing
happened until 1750 and suddenly
everything is happening and even 10,000
years is an incredibly short time
historically speaking I mean the lesson
I take from this that is relevant to
where we're gonna go in the conversation
is we are nowhere near equilibrium right
like our situation is incredibly rapidly
changing and therefore we have every
justification for imagining that a
thousand years from now things are gonna
be dramatically dramatically different
in some way whether or not we can
predict what that way is gonna be right
yeah so the assumption that the future
is gonna look much like the past at
least at a certain time horizon looks
like a dubious assumption you know I
don't know if this is a good idea to
bring it up but yeah I'm just listening
to your interview with Martin Rees which
was released this week which just
probably means nothing by the time this
comes out I don't know when this will
actually but and he made the similar
point of it you have people building
cathedrals in the Middle Ages why do
they do that when they wouldn't have to
see them because they presumed that
their children would live in a very
similar world and appreciate the same
things and how nowadays that assumption
looks a lot of us are questioning that
more because it feels like the future
might be radically different from the
past yeah absolutely and you know by the
way it is always appropriate to mention
previous podcast episodes that we've
done and and you can do the same thing
for your own podcast episodes that's
that's perfectly fine so the part of
this
the change that you care about is
broadly construed automation or I guess
more specifically the effect it's having
on jobs and work you know we used to be
hunter-gatherers and it basically
everyone had a job either hunting or
gathering or doing the support work for
hunters and gatherers and things have
changed a lot I mean why don't you just
give us your potted quick explanation of
how work has changed over the years yeah
the basic story is that the tasks that
humans used to perform are increasingly
being performed by machines or a through
kind of a lot of technological
assistance so even if you don't have
tasks that are fully automated you have
tasks that are automated - such a
percentage that the human performed
element of the task is quite limited and
you can see this in many different
sectors of societies that's one of the
things I tried to do in the opening
chapter of this books and in the sketch
different domains of society and how
we're seeing this trend towards what I
call human obsolescence it's probably
you know a dramatic way of putting it or
a strong way of putting it and but I
think the trend is very clear again
agriculture if you want to start with
that example you have fairly precipitous
declines in the number of human beings
employed in agriculture since the 1800s
or 1900s you know most European
economies and the u.s. majority of
workers worked in agriculture in the
eighteen hundreds up until the early
1900s and now we're talking about less
than 5% of humans employed in
agriculture yeah that's a these are
statistics actually that I based from
nickel Max rouser our world and data has
a lot of nice charts and information
about this similar story is true in
manufacturing although I think there
it's much more apparent to people
because manufacturing is one of the
industries that has most clearly
automated because the science of
automation or so so visible there's a
stereotypical image of the production
line like a motor car factory or
something is a clear illustration of
this trend towards automation we also
see in another area so I look at the
impact on the professions the rise of
automated assistance in medicine in law
as well and also in science so like I
talked about some examples and you're
more familiar with this than I would be
but there are clearly increasingly
science is any big data enterprises lots
of computerized assistance with
performing statistical analysis and
calculations but there's also some
initial evidence that we're creating
robots that can perform their own
experiments as a team in university and
have risks within Wales that have
created these robots Adam and Eve that
run their own experiments they can look
at their own policies and test their own
experimental e test these hypotheses
reach conclusions so it's a time when
we're seeing this kind of rapid trend
towards automation in many different
sectors and often times when people
discuss this topic they focus on just
one sector of society rather than all of
them and one of the things I wanted to
do is to try and give a a wide sketch of
all these different domains of activity
yeah actually I really liked an example
that you had which is completely obvious
and I feel bad for sort of not just
figuring it out myself but the financial
trading literally on the floor of the
New York Stock Exchange the idea that
that is more or less going away and now
we just use the stock exchange as a
backdrop for video cameras you know a TV
shows and things like that but all of it
has become automated in the real world I
mean I knew that intellectually but the
vivid picture of the trading floor more
or less disappearing really hit home
yeah so this notion that the trading
floor is a place for you get lots of
people crowded together
barking buy and sell orders at each
other kind of the image you see in a
movie from the 1980s
Trading Places with Eddie Murphy and oh
yeah classic dan Aykroyd you know
there's that's the stereotypical view of
the market nowadays yes most trading
activity takes place digitally and in
fact most trading activity is performed
by by algorithms the estimates are a
little bit tricky here but most people
assume on pretty good grounds it's more
than 50% of all trades are executed by
yeah
yeah I mean like I said I sort of knew
this intellectually but after reading
your book I
was moved to go look at the data here
now it was I think it's true that this
does literal size of the new york stock
exchange floor peaked in the 1990s it
expanded but then it's been shrinking
ever since they've literally been you
know cutting off the floor space because
if they need it less and less so that it
says something about how our society is
changing yeah yeah there's a regulatory
reason for that as well which is just to
do with the nationalization of markets
in the US so the the the physical
location of New York is less important
than it ever was party due to technology
but also need you to changes in
regulation oh well it's always these
details that make the story a little bit
less romantic but ok but ok so that I
mean that gives us a bit of a background
and I think that probably most listeners
get it that there's a lot of more
automation but let's be let's take into
what it does mean across the different
sectors I mean I have this feeling that
throughout the last several hundred
years this in that particular industry
has become automated but it's always
been the case that jobs for human beings
have popped up somewhere else right like
we've lost a lot of farming jobs and a
lot of industrial jobs but there's jobs
than doing other things that have popped
up and you're trying to make that much
stronger case that we're entering a sewn
where some jobs will be automated and
there won't be replacements for them and
the total number of jobs to be done by
humans is gonna precipitously decline
yeah I mean I think you have to be a
little bit careful when we talk about
this topic so I'm gonna do maybe
something boring and philosophical which
is to define some of the terms that get
bandied abandoned claims they should
know we appreciate that you've come to
the right put podcast right so may i
frame my discussion in the book about
the automation of work and i do that
partly because that's the way which a
lot of people talk about it and but it
is a little bit misleading in the sense
that work is a very vague term and
people mean different things by it so
what i mean by it is the performance of
skills in return for some kind of
economic reward so at least for me work
isn't any particular activity or task it
is rather a condition under which humans
perform tasks
so it's a little bit of an abstract
notion and a job then yet is effectively
a socially or economically defined role
that is made up of a bunch of tasks
things that you do in which you then
receive some kind of economic reward in
return for doing those tasks so you know
if you're a taxi driver you drive people
around from here to there according to
their wishes
you might small talk with them or
something so these are all tasks that
make up that that job and when we talk
about the automation of work and the
automation of jobs it's the it's
misleading to assume that technology
necessarily displaces work and
necessarily to play displaces jobs
because what technology really does is
it tends to change the tasks that make
up jobs and make up work and so right so
this kind of links into your point which
is that because jobs are really defined
as collections of tasks we might
automate 40% of those tasks but there's
oftentimes other tasks that humans can
move into and that are often humans
haven't comparative advantage in
performing relative to machines so
automation doesn't necessarily lead to
the displacement of jobs we can
sometimes redefine our roles so that we
can focus on different tasks and so this
is what we see historically is that
technology has very clearly had a
disruptive impact on lots of jobs but it
hasn't necessarily led to wide scale
unemployment because people have moved
into other kinds of jobs that are
defined by different sets of tasks and
some economists refer to this is the the
complementarity effect of Technology so
a lot a lot of times we focus on the
substitution effect of technology the
technology substitutes for human labor
but oftentimes it there's a they're
complementary tasks humans can perform
alongside machines that can opens up a
whole Vista or new space of work or at
the future and this is why we haven't
seen this trend towards constructor
alone employment over the long term as a
result of technology yeah I mean I think
that the point of jobs as a category are
socially constructed it's a very good
one right it's not literally something
it needs to be done it's a way we're
choosing to
organize our society to give people
reward monetary rewards for doing these
tasks like you say so if that's true how
can we ever say that we're confident
that jobs are going to go away or that
you know the the need for human beings
to do jobs will become less and less can
we always invent new constructions of
what we mean by a job yeah so it's but
it's possible that you read my book is
arguing for the extreme thesis that and
all work is going away but what I would
say is that I don't think that's
something that necessarily happens I
think it's something that depends to a
large extent on how society responds to
automation so I'm not a technological
determinist or fatalist about these
things I think there are choices that we
make
individually Society and institutionally
that will make a difference to this as
to whether we always find new jobs but I
am skeptical about the potential for us
to always find new complementary tasks
that humans can perform alongside robots
or AI which will be solutions for a kind
of mass employment and I mean there are
a few different reasons for my
skepticism and I discuss four of them in
the book one is just that there is some
preliminary data suggesting that when
employers turn to robots or automation
it doesn't tend to increase the overall
level of work or doesn't have a neutral
effect on rocket ends to actually reduce
the number of workers demanded so
there's some interesting empirical work
done by Daron Acemoglu and Pascale
Restrepo I think they're both in MIT and
they did work on US labor markets where
they suggested that for every robot it
company uses in the US it tends to
displace either between three and six
workers so there's a kind of net loss of
employment that was data based on from
1990 to 2007 and then more more recently
they did a study of French companies who
automate it and they saw a similar
effect number one that these these
companies tended to increase their
productivity pretty dramatically and
they had a larger share of the over
productivity in the French market and
also they intended to reduce the number
of workers that they employed so there
is that initial empirical data it's just
two studies I'm mentioning here which
suggest that the use of robots in
particular doesn't lead to gains or
neutral level of employment it seems to
lead to net losses overall but isn't
that I mean I I think I'm sort of just
pushing a little bit because I'm
probably going to agree with your thesis
overall but that data seems to indicate
that within those particular industries
robots came in and human beings went out
but then other industries come up right
i mean we have kinds of jobs we didn't
have before so but you want to argue
that we're at a point now where I think
you want to argue tell me that it's good
that jobs are going away that we should
imagine moving toward a future where we
don't even we're not sad that there are
fewer jobs for human right and I mean
just to say one thing on the empirical
evidence so a smugglin Restrepo do look
at the scenarios whether there are jobs
being created in other sectors of the
economy at least when they did--they
study in the US and they didn't find a
net gain so when they looked within
particular industries they saw a higher
level of net loss but even when they
looked across industries they saw a
still at a net loss overall for every
robot employed today assigned okay and
one of their points which i think is
good one is that this is at a point in
time when there's actually been
relatively little use of robots so from
1990 to 2007 there was relatively little
uptake of robot ization in the US
industries and since then it's actually
increasing and we probably expect it to
increase in the future so this is yeah
maybe we should also talk about just
just to make things a little bit more
concrete what are the kinds of jobs
where it's easy to imagine robots taking
over or automation taking over and the
ones where it's hard you mentioned fruit
picking as one where it's hard but it's
nevertheless becoming true perhaps and
then there's also you know more
intrinsically human jobs like government
or being a scientist or being an artist
and you're trying to make the case that
even in those we can imagine robots
doing what human beings currently do
yeah I mean there's a roboticist called
Hans Moravec who formerly this thing
called more of X paradox back in the
1980s we talked about how actually how
high-level cognitive jobs are oftentimes
the easiest things to automate because
they tend to be very easy to formulate
an algorithm to perform those tasks
whereas physical manual labor is often
the most difficult thing to automate
because it relies on kind of
unpredictable alert that's easily
controlled stochastic variables and I
don't know if his framing of it is
correct I think what most people would
say nowadays is that their routine work
is easily automatable and anything
that's non routine is a little bit more
difficult to automate although the new
kinds of AI that we are developing seem
to be getting better at performing even
these non routine tasks the things that
we thought traditionally were were hard
to automate so yeah that's just one
point on like what kinds of jobs we can
expect to see to see automated it seems
to be that probably more and more jobs
we can expect as the automated based on
current technological trends that's true
even if there are limits to the current
systems of AI that we currently deploy
and exhibit there's a lot of room for
different uses of the technology that we
currently have that haven't been tried
out yet I'm kind of I do lost the throne
of your original question though so well
you know I think the problem just trying
to you know raise this idea that I'm
sure is in many people's minds that sure
I can imagine you know financial trading
or building cars being replaced by
robots but I can't imagine being a pop
star or being a law professor being
replaced by robots right right so it's
certainly intuitive lis possible to me
that our artistic jobs or entertainment
industry jobs are probably not going to
be subject to kind of wide scale
automation there are people who are
building you know holographic pop stars
in Asia
I've seen several examples of this and
there are people who are building or
creating algorithms that can make the
next Beatles album a famous example from
a few years ago but I dare - I haven't
skeptical is whether people will be that
interested in robot or computer created
art I think it's interesting as a
novelty initially but I think there is
something in art that we like the human
origin and the human story behind it and
that that was often cast for more than
just the end product and we see this
anyway in you know debates about our
action forgery you know a perfect
forgery is never as good as the original
artwork why is that I think and part of
the reason is that we we care about the
origin of artworks more than we care
about let's say the origin of furnitures
or laptops you know broadly speaking
some people do care but the origin of
those things but that tends to be it
looked really good but the the idea of
you know automating pop stars that
shouldn't fire provide much reassurance
for people in the notion that that is a
type of work that's gonna be relatively
resilient to automation should be that
reassuring because that's never been a
job for the masses of people these are
always jobs reserved for the elite view
these are so-called superstar markets
where the handful of individuals tend to
extract most of the value from those
markets so yeah I don't think we should
be reassured by that notion there are
other kinds of jobs that we might expect
to hold up or be more resilient to
automation like care work or any form of
work where the human touch is deemed to
be important but I'm not entirely
convinced that they will be that
resilient automation either because
oftentimes these are jobs a few humans
really want to perform I mean one of the
debates that where this comes up most is
in care of the elderly for example lot
of people argue that we shouldn't use
robots to automation to care of the
elderly and I think they have good
ethical reasons for thinking that we
might not want to do that but I think
there is a significant pressure to do it
because a lot of people don't like
performing that kind of dirty care work
so to speak and also
and there's a demographic challenge here
as well which is we've got increasingly
aging populations and we need to do
something to to care for them so I mean
one of the conscious where you see the
most automation of care workers in in
Japan and which is one of the oldest
populations the world that's partly due
to reasons of restricting the emigration
into Japan that's also I think partly
because of that demographic challenge
that younger generations in Japan don't
really want to perform this kind of work
or unable to before this network right
yeah I remember Kate darling for example
who I did have on a previous podcast
developing robots to help care for
elderly people so that that does sound
like the kind of thing where you when
you first say the words people are like
oh no that could never be done in
automation but maybe it could once you
just think about it a little bit more
there's probably a lot of examples of
that yeah and I mean just to be clear
I'm not necessarily saying that robots
are going to do a better job in those
industries there are some industries
where robots clearly would do a better
job than humans because these are
industries that pride themselves on you
have a speed and precision so I think
financial trading is another good
example of that but it's just that
there's even if the robots are less good
than humans at performing them there
might not be a huge supply of human
labor into those industries for other
demographic or social reasons okay but
we're mostly here not to say that
automation is taking over but you want
to argue I think the more novel part of
your argument is and that's good right
your book is called automation and
utopia and I think that you're doing a
good thing by sort of at least the
labeling is a little bit extremist
you're much more measured in the actual
text but you're saying like let's just
imagine a world where work becomes
completely optional so so what do you
have against work what did I hear
arguments that it would be better if we
didn't have to have jobs to earn a
living yeah and so I think this is
oftentimes the key question that what I
call in the book the desirability
question which is I can do we want to
for humans to keep working and remain
competitive with machines or to find
other jobs for them that compliment
machines and one of my this is a more
radical view in the book was that we
probably shouldn't want that and there
are several reasons for it and I explore
them in
in a chapter I think I have five
different arguments for thinking that
work is a bad thing and in fact it's
something that's being made worse by
technology in a lot of instances so the
argument is probably complex insofar as
it breaks down into five parts but you
know very briefly the reasons why I
think work is a bad thing and we should
encourage it's automation is that work
tends to undermine freedom of choice
it tends to exert this kind of
domination influence over our lives I
think technology is making work worse
for a lot of people it's they didn't do
the the fishery of the workplace a lot
more outsourcing a lot more short-term
contract work precarious work gig work
seems to be an increasing phenomenon of
technologically brokered marketplaces
like uber and deliver you or other
companies like this and also there's a
significant amount of inequality in work
nowadays both in terms of income
disparity which appears to have been
growing since the 1980s and there's an
interesting story you can tell there
that that increase in income disparity
seems to have been correlated with a
period of time where you see increased
automation in middle income middle skill
jobs in particular in the US and so
there's there's inequality in terms of
income but there's also I think another
interesting form of inequality in work
which is inequality in terms of the
quality or meaningfulness of the work
which is a phenomenon that is discussed
by a guy called David Order MIT based
economists does a lot of work on
manufacturing and outsourcing but he
talks about this polarization effect on
the in the labor market as a result of
technology that people are pushed into
either low skill low income work or high
skill high income work and just remember
listen to this economists define low
skill in a maybe a counterintuitive way
in that it's just the amount of years of
education you need to enter a job it
defines whether it's higher those skills
so there's lots of low skill work that
is highly skilled right it's it's not
really a measure of skill but the sort
of background prerequisites you need to
take up the job yeah exactly so people
are pushed into these lower skill forms
of works which are often more arduous
and more
tends to be kind of complex physical
manual work which is not always pleasant
and has lots of maybe health and
long-term health repercussions for
people involved in it and but most
people go into that low skill bracket
because there are relatively fewer high
skill high income jobs and there's also
higher barriers to entry into those jobs
so you see this this polarization effect
in terms of the quality of work the
meaningfulness of the work that people
perform another reason for not favoring
why employment is that I think work is
increasingly colonizing our lives to use
a strong term in that yeah because the
labor market is increasingly competitive
and work is more precarious as a result
of technology so the people who spend a
lot more time and attention on upscaling
themselves trying to make themselves
employable worrying about employment so
even if we're not spending more time at
work and there's some evidence to
suggest that the amount of hours that
people spend per year working has gone
down we're spending a lot more time
thinking about work and caring about
work I mean I have one an exception in
the book which I think is illustrative
of this actually comes from another
author David frame who wrote an
interesting ethnography of workers in
the UK a few years back and he describes
a story where he was interviewing a 12
year old boy and a local school because
he was doing some classes with the local
school some extracurricular classes and
he asked this boy why he did the class
and did he enjoy it and the boy said
yeah it was enjoyable but the main
reason why I did it is that it would
ultimately look good on his CV which is
like a very odd thing for I think a
twelve-year-old to be caring about which
is like building up their CV and their
employability
no that's that's an actor but that's I
think for illustrative of a general
trend and the other final reason I have
liked for thinking that the automation
of work is a good thing is that when you
look at some of the evidence on whether
people enjoy work that there's some
evidence is just that they tend to be
quite dissatisfied with work so the
Gallup they do these large surveys of
the global work force every few years
and one of the consistent findings from
their surveys over the past 15 years or
so is that most people express
dissatisfaction with the work that
they're doing they don't feel yeah fully
engaged by it and I think partly that's
driven by the highly competitive and
precarious nature of the workplace that
people think they could be doing better
or they're worried about the security of
their jobs so well maybe yeah I mean
maybe it's worth expanding a little bit
on the point that you raised but I think
is worth diving into about the gig
economy and about the structure of work
these days where jobs seem to be a bit
more ephemeral I'm not sure how much
data there is saying if that's true but
it's certainly the feeling we get and it
I could imagine that there is something
structural about the modern age which
makes employment less secure and less
long-term is that an accurate assessment
yeah like there's a there's an
interesting book about this actually by
a guy called Andrew Weil called the
Fisher Trek place where he explores why
this happened historically and so really
in the middle part of the 20th century
there was a trend towards very large
corporate organisations which you know
you had a company like let's say Ford
motorcars who employed huh lots of
people and lots of very diverse workers
under the same corporate umbrella so you
know they would hire catering staff
they'd hire accountants workers at
higher IT they'd hire security guards
and groundskeepers so on all employed
within the same organization and since
the 1970s there's been a shift away from
that notion of the big corporation that
hires everybody to do all the tasks that
are relevant to the whatever products
they're producing or whatever service
they're providing and instead what you
find is that companies are focusing on
what they view is their core competency
and then they're outsourcing a lot of
the other forms of work and two
part-time contractors or other companies
that specialize in say the provision of
accounting services or security staff
and so on and why has that happened well
there are a couple of reasons why that's
happened one is that it's actually tends
to be a more attractive way of arranging
a corporation
from the perspective of shareholders and
consumers because it tends to increase
the returns to shareholders because you
reduce the costs that you paid
oftentimes when you do this kind of
fishing and outsourcing and it tends to
also reduce costs to consumers or tends
to be more productivity but workers tend
to get the worst deal in this this
arrangement and yeah and also technology
has facilitated this and so far is one
reason traditionally why you wouldn't
outsource workers is that you wouldn't
be able to easily monitor them and
ensure that they were complying with
corporate standards but the advances in
surveillance technology have enabled
kind of greater consistency and
enforcement of corporate standards and
one area where this is like really
transparent is in truck drivers and the
amount of ongoing surveillance of truck
driver drivers which has been true for
quite some time now and but this trend
towards increased surveillance is
creeping in in other industries as well
and it certainly sounds reminiscent to
in the academic context of a shift
towards adjunct professors right short
term contracts rather than tenured
professors we're going to be there for
many decades yeah and so that's another
illustration of this phenomena of this
drive towards precarious forms of of
labor I mean I haven't really
investigated in detail the reasons for
that in the in academia and I think part
of it probably has to do something like
the research funding culture that people
get bought out on research grants and
tend to employ a part-time labor to
cover their teaching allocation that's a
trend at least in the UK and Ireland and
is probably more attractive as well from
a managerial perspective that it allows
you to efficiently deliver mass higher
education on a kind of tight budget or a
cut budget yeah but okay so this
argument seems to amount to not an
intrinsic indictment of work but a
change in how work is organized in our
society that sort of makes it less
rewarding and stable and and
psychologically helpful right I mean so
and and maybe this is a sign of this
shift this transition that we're in the
middle
of it from everybody work society into a
people don't necessarily work society
yeah so it could be what we're observing
now is kind of friction or teething
problems as we transition from one
society to the other and I mean to
underlie a point that you just made and
I think is important one is that my
critique of work isn't that work is
intrinsically bad because if you go back
to the definition that I offered earlier
work work isn't any particular activity
it is rather a condition under which we
perform an activity and my argument is
that the conditions under which we
perform work perform our jobs are tend
to tend to be getting worse for the
majority of workers that's not to say
that there aren't people who benefit
from the current system there clearly
are but the majority seem to be losing
out on the current arrangement well we
miss if we didn't at least bring up the
arguments that I'm sure some people are
thinking that there is an intrinsic
value to work right that the work ethic
is a good thing to have that people get
a sense of identity or even
meaningfulness from the jobs that they
do and so couldn't someone say the thing
to do is not to give in to the
elimination of work but to reorganize
the economy so that jobs are more secure
and rewarding yeah so there is a
widespread discussion of this in kind of
philosophical literature about what work
which is you know meaningful work is
what we should care about and work is
oftentimes the important cent part of
people's identity and sense of meaning
and purpose in life and I'm very
sensitive to that concern all right
that's something I care about but if you
take one example of this that I discuss
in the book there's a couple of
philosophers who wrote an article called
the goods of work other than money and
they identify four things that people
get out of work apart from an income
they get a sense of mastery over some
skill set they get to form alliances and
friendships with people in the workplace
so they at the sense of community they
also get to contribute to their
societies in some way sometimes positive
maybe sometimes not so positive but it's
oftentimes the main way in which people
contribute to society is through their
work and also they get a sense of social
recognition and status which of course
people care about
a lot they want to be respected and
recognized by their peers and so if
people didn't work they would lose these
four things so what do you wanna do
about it and my response to that is that
you you could lose those four things
that's definitely true but the question
I would have is whether work is the only
way in which we can get a sense of
mastery contribute to our societies have
a sense of community and gain
recognition and I'm not convinced that
it is the only way that we can get those
things I think there might be other fora
that we can look into for pursuing those
non income related goods of work I mean
it's a pretty dramatic shift right I
mean I don't know how what we counted if
10,000 years ago when people were
hunter-gatherers do we count that as
work I mean it was doing a kind of job
but I what I want to say is that
literally throughout all of history
people have worked and you're you're
suggesting not the only one to suggest
but that that's coming to an end and
there's there's gonna be some most alger
for that period of human history right
oh I mean absolutely a baby I think
about hunter-gatherers this is a very
interesting paper written back in the
sixties I think by Marshall Sahlins
called the original leisure society and
you've all know a Harare made a lot of
this in one of his books I think the
first one sapiens so this notion that
actually hunter-gatherers were the
original leisure society because they
spent very little time every day working
to I mean in terms of getting their food
they spent a couple of hours that doing
that and then the rest of their day was
quite quite leisurely and they seemed to
derive a lot of kind of meaning and
satisfaction for that well one thing I
would say is that the the level of
attachment and nostalgia you have for
work is probably a function of the kind
of work that you currently do so people
like you and I who are in these
high-skilled jobs we're you know we're
rewarded for complex creative
problem-solving and we like to complain
but is we have it pretty good yeah I
mean that is we can complain of edge but
we have it pretty good and we also have
a lot of autonomy over what we do which
a lot of work don't have we are probably
the people who are most
attached to the current system and most
worried about listening out of that
because our work is such a core part of
our identity and this is actually one
things I mentioned the book is that for
me the notion that I would lose my job
which that would be significant I think
I would I would definitely feel that as
a loss because my work is so intrinsic
to my sense of who I am but I think I
have to be sensitive to the fact that I
am in a relatively privileged position
and not everyone feels the same way and
lots and lots of people nowadays get
most of their satisfaction and sense of
purpose and meaning from non
work-related activities from their
families from community work from their
hobbies and other interests well good
and that leads us into you know I think
the the big payoff here you you you
imagine a couple different scenarios for
how we could cope with this transition
into a world where work was not taken
for granted to something everyone has to
do and and then you argue that this
could be a good thing so I won't put the
words into your mouth I'll tell us how
we could make a transition and why it
might be good yeah this is a way that I
set this up in the book and there's also
a part of this discussion which we've
left out so far which is that I have a
long discussion of all the negative
things that technology does to our lives
as well and the ways in which it can
compromise our our freedom and our
autonomy and our attention and all that
even in a non-work domain but setting
that to the side actually I you know
that I think that's fair and maybe it's
my fault for not bringing that up but
let's let's give a couple minutes to say
that because I think it is a point worth
making I mean what is your argument
about the downsides of Technology
because there are techno utopians techno
pessimists and there's probably good
arguments on both sides but it's worth
having them in the back of our brains as
we contemplate this transition right so
I mean this notion that we you know
we're going to abandon work and what are
we going to do as a result well there
are kind of satirical dystopian versions
of what that might entail that don't
look very very pleasant so I'm one of
those that I discuss in the book is from
the Pixar movie wall-e
which is one model of wash a future in
which automated technologies become yes
widespread
is like and it doesn't look to be a very
pleasant one so for people who aren't
familiar with the movie it depicts a
future in which the earth has been
completely despoiled by high-technology
and it's you know it the pollution is
rampant and the world is covered in
trash and humans have migrated onto
these off planet ships are trying to
find a new home humans have become
incredibly obese they ride around at
these motorised chairs all day they get
fed a constant stream of light
entertainment and fast food and all
around them on these interstellar ships
that they're traveling on are these
robots that really do do all the work
and that doesn't look like a very
pleasant future because it seems to
reduce humans to this kind of passive
space where we enjoy some of the
benefits that technology brings their
lives the conveniences of technology but
we don't really do anything so we're not
the agents that are controlling our
future any meaningful sense and because
at least in the modern era and liberal
Western societies we tend to really
pride and value our sense of agency and
autonomy this looks like a serious
threat sesh automating technologies
could pose to us that they could cut us
out of the picture and reduce us to
essentially servants of the Machine so
to speak mmm-hmm yeah I think that's I
think that is something to worry about
but we have some choice in how we're
going to shape it so how do we avoid
that yeah this is how I set it up in the
book is that if you imagine that as a
negative future that we want to avoid
well there's kind of two things we can
do or two ways of responding to it and a
way of thinking about the challenge that
technology poses to us which is that
increase in the technology seems to be
pushing humans out of the cognitive
niche concept from evolutionary
psychology and evolutionary anthropology
that I borrow as a metaphor for
discussing this in the book so humans
have evolved that we've become
successful because of our cognitive
powers and our capacity for a complex
problem solving but increasingly we are
ceding that territory to machines so
what do we do in response well is really
two things we can do
we can race against or say yeah fight
back against the machines in a sense by
trying to become more like them more
like the machines that are replacing us
I call these basically right I call this
the cyborg solution to our problem where
the pursuit of the cyborg utopia that's
the way I put it in the book or we
concede the territory to machines and
retreat to something else and I call
this pursuing the virtual utopia or
virtual life and I try to investigate
the benefits and costs of both of those
solutions to the problem and I think
there's merit to both of them but
ultimately I try to make the case for
thinking that pursuing the virtual life
is more appealing than it might
initially sound to be okay but let's so
let's dig into the one you don't like as
much first or the cyborg ization how
literal are we taking this are you are
you imagining literally like that I'm
gonna look like the Borg where I you
know have metal pieces hanging onto me
or is it a slightly more metaphorical
version of a cyborg you have in mind
so I think you can take both
perspectives on it right and I suppose
really there's a sliding scale of
cyborgs like futures for us there is the
future in which we really just become
very closely integrated with machines
maybe we replace the majority of our
biological components with machine like
equivalents something like the the Borg
from from Star Trek or there's the other
view way of looking at it ish which is
actually a view that is favored in some
philosophical circles which is that
humans have always been a technological
species we've always had these very
close almost symbiotic relationships
with the technology that we create so
we've always been cyborgs in the sense
and we're becoming more cyborgs like
because we're becoming more dependent on
technology but that technology is still
external to us it's not integrated into
our our biology so I think there's those
kind of two ways of understanding it
either you directly integrate the
technology into our biological systems
possibly even replacing them or you just
have these very close dependency or
inter dependency relationships with
technological artifacts that remain
external to your body so I mean
in particular I know that certain
companies are pursuing some kind of
brain computer interfaces or even neural
implants that will sort of hook us into
the internet or to computers directly is
that a step along the way towards cyber
organization yeah I think so Elon Musk
it's probably the example you're
thinking of the neural link company is
one of the ones that attracted a lot of
media attention anyway but I mean brain
computer interfaces are widespread yeah
and have been for quite some time and
they're used for therapeutic reasons
brain implants are used for therapeutic
reasons and they're also there's a large
community of cyborg hackers who people
who in their own basements or kitchen
laboratories try to implant or if I'd
eat chips into their arms or other maybe
slightly more complex forms of brain
computer interface and so yeah I mean
those were those are some of the
possibilities one of the people I slice
in the book or as an illustration of an
actual living cyborg is an artist called
Neil Harbison who is based in Spain but
he's from Northern Ireland originally
and he wears this device that's
implanted into the back of his skull
that allows him to hear colors
essentially because he's born colorblind
and he has this device that converts
light waves into sound waves yeah and so
he's this kind of like did or
technologically created synesthesia if
you like and he's using technology to
augment or explore different sensory
forms of engagement with the world so
that's a more experimental you see he
defines himself as a a cyborg and
there's some interesting interviews with
him where he says that he doesn't think
that he uses technology in his life he
thinks that he is a bit of technology he
I think he's founded something called
the trans-species Society for people who
have a nonhuman identity basically so
there are people out there who are very
actively pursuing this kind of highly
technologized form of of cyborg
existence and how exactly does this save
us from work or from leaving work I mean
what I'm missing a little connection
there
yes and it doesn't necessarily save us
from from needing work so what it does
is that it if we if we are losing
competence and power to machines if if
the kind of wall-e dystopia is a
realistic one the concern is that we
won't be good at doing anything anymore
and we'll need machines to do everything
for us becoming cyborgs like is possibly
a way of augmenting or enhancing our
capacities so that we don't lose that to
machines but I mean you've perhaps
hinted at one of the big risks of doing
this which I discuss in the book is that
that would probably be seem to be a way
of perpetuating the economy in its
current form in the sense that well if
humans are augmented they become
efficient at performing tasks and people
want to employ them again and in fact I
would have some fears about this that
this might like double down on many of
the worst aspects of the labor market as
we we currently see them the last week's
that I mentioned earlier on in this
discussion so for example I complained
about the highly competitive nature of
the labor market nowadays mmm-hmm one of
the ways in which that competition
manifests itself today is in education
competition for upskilling in the future
if we pursue this kind of cyborg path it
might manifest itself in the way of a
competition for cyborg implants and that
might also lead to increasing inequality
and disparity in the workplace if these
cyborg implants or things that are only
affordable by the elite few I mean even
Harry Potter he had a much better broom
than everybody else and that did help
him in the Quidditch matches so the
technological competition is something
that is very hard to escape exactly yeah
yeah and I mean I think there other
risks associated with trying to pursue
the cyborg path one one person who's put
this I think rather well and this is a
complex problem so I'm gonna treat it
rather clearly here but sure there's an
Irish journalist called Mark O'Connell
there with this interesting book where
he followed a lot of transhumanists or
people who are interested in cyborg
identities and that and he pointed out
there was an odd paradox or tension in
their views which is that a lot of them
are very concerned about how in
efficient human biology is and how
poorly designed our biological machinery
is and they have this sense that we are
constrained and lack freedom as a result
of the constraints of biology and they
want to replace that with technology and
want to speak to become more
technological like people like reycarts
file that want to create digital copies
or uploads of the human mind and he
argues that this seems odd insofar as
you're replacing the biological prison
potentially with a technological prison
so you're substituting one kind of
unfreedom for another kind of one
freedom because you know who controls
the technological infrastructure that
you replace yourself with at the moment
it seems unlikely that it's going to be
individuals it's probably more likely
going to be corporations or people who
have this specialist know how to create
these kinds of technologies so you might
end up enslaving yourself to technology
and becoming less free as a result of
cyber organization so I think that's
another serious concern with this
solution to our predicament or problem
yeah I mean I think it makes sense I'm
not sure if it's true or not because I
don't underst I don't trust my ability
to predict the future but I think it's a
sensible argument you're making that
sure we can try to out-compete the
robots by joining them but then we're
still stuck in this cycle of being
beholden to larger power and economic
structures that don't always have our
good fortunes in in mind and especially
if they've now figured out how to make
human beings more replaceable less
permanently employed etc you know that
that could that would only get worse if
we were cyborgs I would imagine yeah I
mean I think you make an important point
which is something I is worth
emphasizing which is that you know I
don't engage in a prediction game here I
wouldn't be confident of predicting the
future in any any sense I think is that
it's not like a Woody Allen quote about
predicting the future as hard our
prediction is hard particular when it's
about the future something at that I
believe mice Niels Bohr believe it or
not okay sorry I was wrong I only say
that because I thought it was Yogi Berra
and I was
I was wrong I think yeah I think I'm
getting confused and that there's
there's a similar Woody Allen quote but
anyway the less we mentioned him better
so I'm really kind of trying to sketch
different scenarios and in the book and
trying to evaluate them and using kind
of philosophical methods and I I hope
that the logic and structure of the
arguments that I lay out is clear so
that people can easily critique it if
they think it's wrong or that some of
the assumptions underlying it or wrong
and the part of what I wanted to do in
the book was to illustrate a way of
thinking about the future that isn't
cheerleading for a particular future or
saying that it we're all going to doom
and gloom and is trying to be fair to
different possibilities even though I
take stances on some issues and my
confidence level in some of the claims
that make wouldn't be particularly high
well yeah predicting is hard but I think
you do you do my impression is you were
arguing and I'm sort of sympathetic to
it that the more dramatic transition to
the future is actually potentially a
better one one in which we don't try to
out-compete with the robots but we say
you know what robots good take over all
of our work we're gonna start doing
something else and we talk about this as
sort of a virtual reality version of the
future where games and creativity play
an important role so why don't you
sketch out what that might entail yeah
this is in many ways that the trick is
part of the book and it's probably the
part of the book that I've had the most
trouble explaining to people afterwards
so by my simple entry to Western is that
you probably need to read the 60 pages
in the book that are dedicated to it to
understand what I'm saying but I'll try
my best to summarize so what I say in
the book is that there's a stereotypical
view of wash a virtual reality future
might look like and there is another
more counterintuitive view and I favor
the counterintuitive view and I think it
could be a good thing
so the stereotypical view is that a
virtual future is one in which we all
plug into the matrix or plug into some
computer-generated virtual environment
so yeah for those of you familiar with
it one of the examples I use in the book
is Neal Stephenson's novel Snow Crash
where he talks about the Metaverse is
something that people spend a lot of
time living and experimenting in um and
you know I think that's that could be
understood as a vision of a virtual
future but there are some tensions
within that insofar as a lot of things
that take place in computer-generated
environments are in my mind quite real
and that you know you have real
friendships and real conversations with
people and mm-hmm sometimes you can
really harm or hurt people in virtual
interaction so I I talk about this film
on as well of virtual assault assaults
committed via a computer avatar virtual
environment and so you know it's not
clear to me that that's really a virtual
world entirely in a the philosophically
strict sense of what virtual would mean
so the other alternative view at the
country intuitive view is that in a
sense humans have always been a virtual
species and this is kind of the
counterpoint to this notion that we've
always been cyborgs we also always kind
of been virtual in the sense that we
have always used technology to create
insulated environments or niches in
which we can survive that are hidden or
shielded from a lot of real-world
effects hmm right and you know I'm not
talking to you right now in the real
natural world so just begun know I'm
inside a nicely centrally heated home
and I mean we manifestly are talking to
each other in the real world mediated by
this wonderful electronic piece of
technology so I think that's exactly to
your point that there's maybe not a hard
to fast line between yeah real real and
virtual real exactly so so the
counterintuitive view is really that
we've have been using technology to kind
of create environments that are more and
more conforming to our desires and needs
and are less constrained by some of the
limits of the physical or natural world
and we can continue to pursue this trend
and in such a way that we we have ever
more control over the kinds of
environments in which we interact and
that's the kind of vision of the virtual
future that I thought I care about I
mean there's there's a related point
here which is that some people argue
that a lot of current existence is a
kind of virtual reality game and some
people like David Graeber is an
anthropologist or he's a lot of work is
virtual reality a sort of [ __ ] jobs
to use his phrase I don't know is it's a
censored podcast so glad to say that go
ahead yeah and and then there's people
like you've all know our Harare is wrote
in a few books about this where he talks
about religion as being a virtual
reality game it's probably a claim
that's gonna offend a lot of religious
believers and also like consumer
capitalism as being like a virtual
reality game that there's nothing we
don't have to live life the way we're
currently living at it's kind of a
socially constructed fact and it might
be associate constructive fact that not
a lot of us have control over but the
more control we get over it the more
virtual it starts to seem to us and
that's kind of though yeah I think I
understand that perspective but it seems
to be stretching the meaning of the word
virtual beyond what is really useful
it's rosário of the social construction
of reality right and the point being
made is that I mean it's art not even
reality being socially constructed but
the human rules and regulations that we
invent are clearly invented and we
invent a whole bunch of different ones
depending on the contexts and we can
continue to invent them with or without
electronic aids and so this is a sense
of the word virtual reality in which
we're being a little bit more self
conscious about the construction of our
ways of living yeah I mean so you've
kind of actually summarized the point
better than I've I've ever been able to
summarize it myself and so I agree that
this is kind of a stretch from how
people typically understand virtual
reality and that's why I talked about
the stereotypical view initially but I
actually think that this counter
intuitive understanding of us is more
appropriate and
gonna have a longest discussion of the
philosophical reasons for thinking that
in in the book but yeah the more
self-conscious we are about the
arbitrary rules and regulations we use
to construct our engagement with the
world the more of a virtual life we're
living and the kind of apotheosis of
this trend is where we start to realize
that everything we're doing is
essentially a game and we have control
over the rules of that game
yeah when reading your book you know the
word game also struck me a little bit
there is they're sort of both narrow and
broad definitions of that you know I've
talked on the podcast about you know the
idea of games and how important they are
but people really these days I think
some people are gonna think of playing
fortnight or you know something on your
computer where it's a video shoot them
up kind of game or some sort of matching
game on your smartphone whereas there's
this broader notion of sort of a
structured activity with a goal right
where we clearly make up the rules but
you know baseball is a game and knitting
is a game and chess is a game and in
some sense the financial markets or
universities or novel-writing is a
different form of game yeah so I think
that's right and I think yeah people
will probably run towards this maybe
computer game scenario or understanding
of it but I do adopt this broader and
definition of a a structured activity
with a goal and I also crucially one
that is dictated or guided by arbitrary
rules and this is a definition of games
that actually comes from a book by
Bernhard suits a philosopher wrote an
interesting quirky book in the 1970s
called the grasshopper it's a dialogue
of Plato style dialogue where they talk
about the definition of a game and the
notion of utopia and so I draw heavily
on that in the book when I discuss this
idea mmm-hmm but I think so I do think
technology plays an important role in
how game-like our existence can be in
one sense which is that technology gives
us more opportunities to construct more
kinds of games oh and because it's more
control over the arbitrary rules we used
to structure our lives now
I mean to go back to the point that you
know the financial market is a game in a
sense that's that's true and that's
something that I I'm conscious of and
work in the modern world could be viewed
as a game but what I think is is
different about the modern world and the
future that I'm sketching is that at the
moment work is largely a necessity for
people it's something that they have to
do they don't have a choice so the
future I'm imagining this virtual future
is what you actually do have a choice
over the kinds of game that you get to
play good and that by that construction
that sounds like something good I just
want to sort of push a little bit on the
word arbitrary that you've used to
describe the rules of the game I would
not call rules of any game arbitrary
like the rules of basketball are not
arbitrary we made them up but we made
them up with the goal in mind like there
are changes to the rules which would
clearly make the game worse and there
are changes that would make it better
so it's not like they were random which
i think is a sense that people get from
using the word arbitrary yeah that's a
fair point so I guess they are their
contingent in some sense are there and
they're unconstrained in some sense by
so oh well I mean that might be entirely
right either but so they are an exercise
of choice and there are better and worse
games and more interesting games and a
large part of that is the function of
the kinds of rules that we choose to
structure our okay good so but that's I
think we're talking about details too
much and not fleshing out the big
picture here I mean you have your tell
us more about what it would mean to
replace our current system of you have
to work to earn a salary and earn a
living with the world where there were
games in some very broad sense of the
term that you could choose to be
involved in and that was where you found
your sort of daily activity and meaning
rather than in your income earning role
in life right so I mean what one part of
this conversation which we haven't
really touched upon and part of the
reason of that is that I don't read such
part of the book which is that all
everything I'm saying is contingent upon
the notion that people aren't suffering
tremendous hardship as a result of
unemployment and from from losing an
income and so I said that issue to the
side in the book and there
are interesting debates and proposals
around things like the basically
comparing tea as a way of solving the
loss of income that people have as a
result of jobs I'm looking more at this
notion of the loss of meaning associated
with jobs and how we could find meaning
in another forum so but sorry so we are
assuming that there is either basic
income or some version of that where
everyone has enough money to survive and
get through the day yeah I mean I'm
probably even more abstract in general
than that insofar as I would say that we
have to have some way of solving the
potential deprivation that people would
have as a result of losing their jobs
the loss of material wealth let's say
right you could have resolved that
through an income that people have to
purchase services but there are other
ways in which you could address the loss
of material wealth as well which
wouldn't necessarily mean that we all
get an income got it and so that there
are different proposals out there for
that but yeah I'm setting that to the
side and I'm assuming that and then I'm
looking at the kind of meaning what do
we do with our time then right yeah this
is the obvious question like let's
imagine that we had no material once and
that I think just to let the audience
know probably you and I both agree that
that is a highly non-trivial question
that should be discussed but it's just
not the question we're interested in
right here we're saying if that were
solved what would we do right exactly
yeah and this is this is a thought
experiment in a sense it's a long
elaborate thought experiment about if
something was the case what would follow
and this is something that I got a lot
of pushback on since I've written the
book which is that I didn't discuss you
know climate change and other disasters
that are facing humanity and you know
part of my response to that is no book
can be about everything that's it I just
wanted to set some issues aside to
explore this kind of space of thinking
so so the future that I've been
visioning is one in which we end up
really having a choice over the kinds of
activity that we pursue in life and I
view these as games because we get to
kind of choose the the rules that apply
to our lives would that be a good thing
is one way of thinking about it and
would it address the the non income
related goods that we might lose through
work so as I mentioned earlier the sense
of mastery social contribution commuter
social recognition can we find those
things in games I think we can you can
get a sense of mastery over a games
sense of skill over gain over the rules
of a game and competency in the
performance of game you can contribute
to society through games and so far as
you can kind of add to the the pleasure
and meaning in other people's lives by
playing games with them you can make
their lives better by participating in
these these activities you can also gain
a sense of social recognition through
games in fact is one of the main ways in
which people currently gain self esteem
or self recognition is through pursuit
of game-like activities and being
rewarded for their competency in game
how many likes you got on Instagram
right that's a version of a game yeah I
mean that might be a negative Russian
team in one sense right and this is one
things all that I would be sensitive to
and discuss maybe a little bit briefly
in the book is that it's not like a game
a future in which we all play games
would be perfect you know there'd still
be the role for competition and there's
there are forms of scarcity in the world
of games that may correspond to the
forms of scarcity we see in the current
world in terms of material scarcity or
income related scarcity in that people
care about being the best to the game
that's a kind of scarcity being the top
ranked performer so there are potential
negatives and downsides to two playing
games but one thing I like about this
vision of the future is that I think it
can be a recipe for kind of mass
satisfaction and appeal hmm it's not
something that it's limited to an elite
few people to make a live a meaningful
life of games or things that can be
pursued by by everybody it also enables
that I think is an open and dynamic
future insofar as that there is a
essentially an infinite horizon of games
that we could possibly explore and I
think this is something that's important
about thinking positively about the
future is that the future should as much
as possible be an open horizon hmm and
not kind of stagnant and closed down in
some sense and oftentimes it's when we
have a sense that the future
is closed and that society is stagnant
that the most pessimism and dystopian
ISM tends to creep in well yeah I mean I
think that it's it's an attractive
picture in some ways but you know
questions do arise that I have and I'm
gonna give you a chance to take a SWAT
at them and and the one you just meant
the issue you just mentioned is one of
them you say that there's an infinite
horizon of possibilities but the flip
side of that is or at least the
counter-argument is what if there's not
what if we just get bored what if we
sort of it turns out that our creativity
for inventing new ways to keep ourselves
amused or or engaged or active isn't as
infinite as we hoped it was is that
something to worry about or something to
make our peace with so I mean this
there's two things to say here one is
that even if the landscape of games
isn't in finished there are there's
often a kind of a relatively limitless
possibility space within individual
games you know people have been playing
chess for thousands of years and a lot
of people still find it intrinsically
fascinating that there's lots of room
left to explore and it even though
machines are better than humans at it so
a human performance chance is still a
popular sport yeah so yeah within an
individual game there's often room for
exploring lots of different spaces
within that game and so that's that's
what point there the point is that would
we get bored and would weaned and run
out of things I think of at a limit of
course we would right I mean if we if we
lived forever literally if our lives
were infinite yeah we'd end up doing
everything and we might become
complacent and bored I just think it's
it seems to me at the moment a good bet
to suggest that there's lots of
possibilities left to explore and lots
of of new game spaces to explore and so
far as we see lots of new games
continually being invented yeah and
again kind of mass traction or appeal
right now but if they become the main
focus of our lives then we have the
opportunity to explore them I think
that's it's just a bet I would
that we're unlikely to run out of things
in any kind of meaningful human time
horizon at the limit we probably would
okay
maybe a more realistic worry is the
following um we talked about the social
construction of the rules maybe they're
not arbitrary but at least we did make
them up and I think that when it comes
to more conventional notions of work
where you're building something and at
the end of the day there's a chair or an
automobile that was created by the labor
of yourself and others even if the rules
of that that social role were made up by
somebody they don't feel like they're
made up by somebody they feel natural or
they feel necessary or they feel sort of
imposed by the constraints of just
living is there some worry that things
begin to seem less meaningful to us if
the rules are obviously socially
constructed like if we're just making up
rules of games in order for us to play
them does that make us less fulfilled
somehow and I can sort of guess the
answer but I'm asking the question in a
leading way yeah I mean this is kind of
a wider debate in the philosophy and on
the meaning of life which is like do you
need some kind of external narrative or
structure in which your life is situated
in order for it to have meaning or do we
embrace the more radical extension which
is that we get to choose what the
meaning is and I tend to favor the
latter view but I would qualify it in
one sense and that it is of course true
that if we invent games we might have an
initially kind of specified rule set
that's clearly arbitrary but we discover
things about the games that we play that
were unexpected or unanticipated given
that initial rule set and we might find
the need to add new rules to the to the
game so to speak so I mean to use one
example you know the rules of a football
or soccer to an American audience and it
didn't include things about players not
being allowed to pass the ball directly
back to the the goalkeeper at one point
in time and the goalkeeper being able to
kick to pick up the ball they changed
that rule because they thought it'll be
more interesting things like the
the offside rule these have been added
to the game or a time because they
realize that the initial set of rules
wasn't sufficiently kind of interesting
and that there are there aspects of the
game they didn't appreciate until they
started to play it more and so there are
I think constraints within the world of
games that we we don't initially
appreciate and yeah the the rule-bound
nature of games isn't fully transparent
to us well and I think I mean another
answer you could have given is everyone
knows that we made up the rules of
football and this does not stop people
from being really really passionately
interested in it right as a matter of
empirical fact yeah I mean so that
that's that's another point which is
this often often times things that are
clearly arbitrary as a matter of
sociological fact an anthropological
fact to take on an outsized importance
in society and actually become the most
important thing in a society yeah which
is kind of an odd feature but yeah the
fact that they are contingent and
socially constructed doesn't seem to
have stopped anyone today from finding a
lot of meaning within them okay so maybe
my most serious question here is you
mentioned the fact when you're talking
about work as it's presently constructed
that there are these power structures
you know there's corporations and
wealthy individuals and there's
inequality that it can be exacerbated by
the current economic setup do we have
any reason to think that won't be just
as bad in the virtual utopia I mean
isn't there at least as much room for
power to be concentrated in certain
hands and abused right along with it so
I definitely think there is room for
there to be power power inequalities and
dynamics and things that need to be
addressed and so the again what I would
make about that is that the virtual
utopia isn't going to be perfect in any
sense the hope is just that it's going
to be better than what we currently have
but do we have reasons for the it's
going to be better than we currently
have
I think there are some reasons for
optimism and so far as if you cut out
the kind of material necessity of work
and so we don't like one of the reasons
why the power dynamics within the
existing economy are so meaningful and
salient to people is because people have
to work to survive and to live right if
you cut out that kind of material
necessity and if everyone gets provided
with a sufficient amount to have a
reasonable quality of life they have
more freedom than to choose the kinds of
activities that they pursue the hope is
that the the power dynamics that might
exist will become less meaningful in a
salient to them and this is also one
area in which technology can help which
goes back to one of my earlier points is
that technology is still part of this
racial utopia and that technology gives
people more options okay I mean I do
think that I get that feeling from our
conversation that a lot of these that
it's harder than I might have thought to
separate out the question of finding
meaning in constructed activities from
the question of how do you pay for it
and where does the where do the material
goods come from I mean I totally respect
the intellectual move of trying to
separate the question of universal
income or the equivalent thereof from
the question of what are we going to do
with our time but I suspect that in
reality there's a very strong feedback
between the two of them and they're
gonna go hand in hand yeah and I think
that's fair and I think that's right
that you're not going to unlock this
utopian future that I'm imagining unless
you solve the problems of kind of
material deprivation or have a world of
relative abundance for it the majority
I'm gonna get a bunch of comments on the
podcast saying that you know we could
have solved all these if Andrew yang had
been elected president of the United
States but we missed our chance on that
one but I don't know I'm argue in favor
of universal basic income let me just
ask that on on as an as an aside I think
I am but I think that we're not sort of
close to being able implemented yet and
it's gonna be an incremental move toward
it rather than a big leap yeah like I'm
probably speaking I'm a fan of the idea
and one of the reasons I'm a fan of the
idea actually doesn't have anything to
do with technology I think there are
lots of interesting ethical reasons to
favor a basic income that aren't linked
to automation which is just that a
basically into kind of allows for more
opportunity and freedom of choice in
life and that tends to be the main
ground on which philosophers have
defended the notion the automation
narrative is only really taken center
stage in the debate around basic income
in the past yeah decade or so but people
have been arguing for it for a very long
time for for other reasons and if people
are interested I have a long ish series
on my blog about the philosophy of the
basic income where I explore the reasons
to be in favor of okay I mean I think
you've given us a lot to think about let
me close with a more provocative aspect
of the whole question so we have jobs in
the current system we work we get income
from that that's a big part of our
self-identity of who we are but there's
another big part which is relationships
family love friendship things like that
is there a parallel argument about how
those aspects of our lives could become
virtual whether it's love or family or a
friendship I said two things about that
one is that the vision of the future
that I'm sketching in this conversation
in the book doesn't rule out the idea
that we'll have relationships and
families and I say this several times in
the book that all those things would
still be available to us that's that's
one issue whether we can have virtual
relationships and virtual companionships
well I think we can and I've written
several papers on this but you know
whether we can have robot friends or
robot lovers and I've written quite a
bit about this over the years and I
think we can under certain conditions
and I mean I can go to those if you want
but that would probably link your
website don't worry I mean so I mean
just very briefly I define myself as an
ethical behaviorist when it comes to our
interactions with virtual others or
machine like others and that if they
look and act like humans or is the same
roughly as humans in all important
respects then we can have meaningful
relationships with them so there is a
possibility for relationships with
machines yeah I mean I think that your
attitude in the book and towards these
things
is one I'm very much in favor of namely
that it is very hard to predict what's
going to happen but it makes all the
sense in the world to imagine all the
scenarios we can't imagine because
things are changing SuperDuper rapidly
and exactly because we can't predict
it's good not to be sanguine it's good
to really you know try to flesh out
ahead of time what the implications of
some things these things could be and
personally I'd be all in favor of
disconnecting the the need to earn a
living from the way we choose to spend
our time during the day yeah and it I
mean really it is about breaking that
link that's what is going to be with
what's valuable to us and the other
thing I would say as well just on a
final note is that this notion of
sketching lots of different scenarios
and plans I mean that I would view that
as being the main thing that I do which
is that I try to imagine different
possible futures and evaluate them using
different kind of ethical norms and
principles so that we get a sense of the
broadness of the axial article landscape
into which we are navigating today
define the word XE illogical I know what
it means but it's axiology is the study
of values so the different kinds of
values associated with these matters
right I find myself at the end of many
of my podcast interviews saying well
it's a brave new world things are gonna
be changing a lot and I think this is
definitely an example of that so John
Danner thanks so much for your insights
here this is a fun conversation yeah
thanks a lot Sean it's great